Hey, Conan here again
with another holiday tune
for the Get Together Foundation
raising money and awareness
for this great cause
that helps kids during
this holiday season.
I thought it was appropriate
that I turn things over
now to a real musician,
Dr. Jimmy Vivino.
Thank you.
And I think folks, we're
gonna play something
we never played before,
and that's the best way.
I've never played this,
so I've never played this,
I have no idea what we're about to do.
We're gonna have a song
by Detroit Junior,
of course everybody's
asking for Detroit Junior,
called Christmas Day.
One!
(drummer drumming)
♪ You know I feel so good ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yo, I feel so good ♪
♪ Well I feel so good ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ You know I feel so good ♪
♪ Well, I feel okay ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause it's Christmas Day ♪
♪ I got a pocket full of money ♪
(lively music)
♪ My baby by my side ♪
♪ I'm so glad ♪
♪ So glad to be alive ♪
♪ That's why I feel okay ♪
♪ On this Christmas day ♪
♪ I want you turn up your hi-fi ♪
♪ Turn it up loud ♪
♪ I want everyone to know ♪
♪ That we're rocking this house ♪
♪ You know I feel okay ♪
♪ On this Christmas day, oh! ♪
(lively guitar music)
♪ We got people in New Orleans ♪
♪ Memphis, Tennessee ♪
♪ Up in Boston, Massachusetts ♪
♪ Down in New Jersey ♪
♪ That's why I feel okay ♪
♪ On this Christmas Day ♪
Let's go!
(lively music)
♪ Well I feel so good ♪
♪ Yeah, yes ♪
♪ Feel so good now ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Well I feel so good ♪
♪ Well I feel okay ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
♪ On this Christmas day ♪
(percussive music)